Transcriber: HİBA HIJAZI ŞEHAB
Gözden geçirme: Ali Eren Kayhan
Kırıcı bir komut bekliyordum ben de.
Evet, burada kendimi görme şansım var mı?
En azından birilerini görme şansım var mı?
Pek bir yanlız hissettim kendimi.
Sahne insanı olduğum için.
Ne yapabiliriz? Tamam. Açtım.
Evet iyi akşamlar arkadaşlar.
Herkese merhaba.
Az önce aslında Türkiye
finalini izlediniz.
Keşke Avrupa finalini
izletebilseydik size
ikinci değil aslında onuncu olduk.
2000 senesinde ülkemizi Stockholm'de
temsil etmiştik.
Onunculuk da fena bir aslında sıralama
değil ama o zamana kadarki en iyi ikinci
dereceydi alınan Türkiye’de
Eurovizyon Şarkı Yarışması benim hayatımda
tabii ki çok büyük bir değere sahip.
Bir defa müzisyenim, sanat icra eden bir
insanım ama aynı zamanda Hacettepe
Üniversitesi İngilizce Edebiyat mezunuyum.
Ankara Üniversitesi İletişim Fakültesi
halkla ilişkiler master derslerini almış
bir insanım.
Öte yandan okumayı çok seven bir insanım.
Tarih öğrenmeyi, okumayı
çok seven bir insanım.
Ama öte yandan da gerçekten iki yaşından,
ta bu zamana kadar
da şarkı söyleyen bir insanım.
Sizin programınızın temasının Echo yani
Yankı olması beni çok heyecanlandırdı pek
çok açıdan.
Neden?
Mesela Eurovizyon şarkı yarışmasında aday
olarak şarkımızı gönderdiğimiz de
rumuzumuz bizim yankı ve oğlumla
iki şarkı göndermiştik.
Oğlum kazanmıştı ama diğeri
de yankı oğlumuzun adıydı .
Biz yakalanmak için aslında sesimizi
sadece ülkemizde değil dünyada duyurmak
için çaba duyardık.
Her zaman atılan her adımın bir sonrası,
belki beş on sonrası vardır diye çalıştık.
Hep öyle hareket ettik.
Dolayısıyla da kendimizde sadece kendi
çapında şarkı söyleyen ya da gruplarıyla
şarkı söyleyen değil, dünyaya sesini
duyuran insanlar olarak hep gördük, hep
öyle koyduk.
Öyle de oldu ve yankılandık.
Yorgunum adlı Anla adlı şarkıyla 2000
senesinde Eurovizyon Şarkı Yarışması’nda
başarıyla temsil ettik.
Neden başarıyla diyorum?
Başarı göreceli bir kavram.
Onuncu olmak çok büyük bir başarı mı?
Değil belki ama bizim asıl başarımız şuydu
arkadaşlar; bir hafta sürer orada
çalışmalar, provalar, kaynaşma dönemidir,
ısınma günleridir o günler.
Bir haftanın sonunda da zaten
finalde yarışma olur.
O bir hafta boyunca sizin diğer
ülkelerdeki yarışmacı dostlarınızla nasıl
ilişki kurduğunuz, kendinizi
nasıl tanıttığını,
nasıl bir diplomasi yürüttüğünüz.
Bu yeteneğinizi nasıl ortaya koydunuz?
Çok çok önemlidir.
Basın toplantısı yapılır her provada.
Sonra bizim basın toplantımızda sonra
şunu söylemişti gazeteciler arkamızdan
Türkiye’den inanılmaz sempatik
bir ekip gelmiş.
Hepsi birkaç yabancı dil konuşabiliyor,
dertlerini anlatabiliyor çok sıcaklar.
Hiçbir kompleksleri yok.
Dost çok güzel dostluklar kuruyorlar.
Gerçekten başarılılar diye arkamızdan
konuşmuşlar.
Bana göre bu da çok pozitif, çok anlamlı,
olumlu bir yankıydı.
Bunun kıymetini de hep bildik biz
tabii aldığımız eğitim, aldığımız
ailelerimizden gördüğümüz edep, adap,
eğitim az önce.
Mesut Alpat da çok güzel bilgiler verdi.
Biz de işte ailelerimizden
o bilgilerle yetiştik.
Neydi o bilgiler biliyor musunuz?
Kadın ve erkek eşittir hatta
hatta her cins eşittir.
Sadece insan değil, doğanın
bir parçasıyız de eşitiz.
Bu anlamda ne bir piramit vardır,
ne bir üçgen vardır.
Herkes bir dairenin içinde eşit, hatta
belki daire dahi yoktur.
Herkes her yerdedir ve gücünün
yettiği kadar
efendim emeğinin yettiği kadar bire
hizmet eder, varlığa hizmet eder.
İşte bizler de bu sevgi anlayışıyla,
bu sevgi saygı anlayışıyla
yetişmiş gençlerdik
ülkemizi temsil etmeye gittiğimizde belki
de o yüzden gözümüzden de sevgi,
yüreğimizden de saygı fışkırıyordu.
O hissettirdik demek ki
diğer ülkelere, dostlarımıza.
Sonrasında sanıyorum beni bu konuşmaya
davet eden sevgili Güneş ve arkadaşları,
sahnede anlattığım hikayeler için biraz
da sizinle beni tanıştırmak istediler.
Yıllarca televizyon programları da
sunduktan sonra ki biliyorsunuz
yankılanmanın, iz bırakmanın, ses
ulaştırmanın en önemli yollarından biri
de medyada olmaktır.
Yirmi küsur sene televizyonda Türkiye
Radyo Televizyon programında sunuculuk
yaptım ve pek çok farklı
programlar sundum.
Şarkılar söyledim.
Gençlik Programı, Bilim
Teknoloji Programı,
Dünden Bugüne Caz Programı.
En son TRT Okul’da efendim her gün canlı
yayın sunarak
pek çok STK, sivil toplum kuruluşlarının
temsilcileriyle bir araya geldim.
O yüzden hem çevremi hem
bilgimi genişlettim.
İşte o sayede.
hem bilgi gördüğümü genişletmiş olmamla
hem sanata karşı
yeteneğimle yıllar sonra sahnede bu defa
tarih anlatmaya karar verdi.
Bilgimi sunmaya karar verdim ama sadece
tarih bilgisine böyle okullardaki efendim
yöntemle değil de tek düze bir yöntemle
değil de sanatla birleştirerek,
edebiyatla birleştirerek yapmaya
karar verdim buna.
Çünkü ben çok iyi biliyorum ki ses, müzik
insanın hayatında
en büyük etki bırakan yöntemdir
bir yoldur, olgudur.
Bunda da çok iyi kullanmak gerekir.
Bunu nerden öğrendim?
Aslına bakarsanız hikaye dönüyor
dolaşıyor, bizim cumhuriyet
tarihimize geliyor.
Ulu Önder Atatürk’ümüze geliyor.
Sahnelerde tarihi anlatmaya karar
verdikten sonra, bilgi paylaşmaya karar
verdikten sonra okumaların
çok ama çok artırdım.
Beni aslında bugüne getiren şey
sanıyorum bu kararımda.
Bundan(7,8) sene önce babam rahmetli babam
dan kalma bir kitap geçti elime kitap.
Kitabın adı Amerikan tarihinde
Türk Kurtuluş Savaşı idi.
Acaba bizim Kurtuluş Savaşımızı
Amerikan tarihi, Amerikan
gazeteleri nasıl anlatıyordu?
Her şey bu hikaye ile bu kitapla
başladı aslına bakarsanız.
O kadar farklı anlatılıyordu ki tarih.
Bizim bildiğimiz, bizim okullarda
öğrendiğimiz şekliyle değil de,
başkalarının gözleriyle, başkalarının
bakış açısıyla da anlatılıyordu.
İşte o zaman karar verdim.
Bilmediğiniz çok şey var.
Öğrenmeniz çok gereken çok şey var.
Başka bakış açılarına da ihtiyacımız var.
Öyle çok hikaye öğrendim ki Cumhuriyet
tarihimizi alakalı hem bunlar hem bizim
nerede hata yaptığımızı anlatan
hikayelerde hem de neyi nasıl
başardığımızı anlatalım hikayelerde.
O hikayelerin arasında bir de bir Özsoy
operası hikayesine rastladım.
Bilmiyorum bileniniz var mıdır?
Özsoy Operası bizim Cumhuriyet tarihimizin
ilk operasıdır gerçek ilk
Türk operasıdır.
Acaba nasıl ortaya çıkmış bir opera?
Neden ortaya çıkmış, nasıl yapmışlar diye
araştırınca ta 1934 senesine kadar
gittim, inanılmaz tabi hikayeler
ve kahramanlarla karşılaştım.
1934 senesinde hikaye şu.
O sene İran Şahı Pehlevi Türkiye'yi
ziyarete gelmeye karar veriyor.
Devrimleri yerinde görmek istiyor.
Atatürk ile de bir araya gelmek
istiyor tabi
bu öyle bir iki günlük bir ziyaret
değil, birkaç ay sürecek.
Dolayısıyla derhal bir protokol
heyeti toplanıyor.
Atatürk'ün emriyle nasıl karşılansın
Şah neler yapılsın diye soruluyor.
Herkes fikrini paylaşıyor.
Kimi diyor ki e paşam neden fabrikalarımız
gezdirmiyoruz tabii diyor.
Çok iyi fikir diyor Paşa.
Peki okullarımızı, kız okullarımızı
gezdirelim, yeni yeni okullar açtık
efendim kıyılarımızda hayvanlarımızı
gezdirelim hepsine tamam diyor.
Olur diyor Paşa.
Fakat bir türlü tamamdır, başlayalım
demiyor.
Finali, efendim koymuyor noktayı.
Bunun üzerine kendisine soruyorlar.
Diyorlar ki sizin aklınızdaki fikir nedir?
Paşa da diyor ki beyefendiler
bir opera besteleyeceğiz.
Şimdi şöyle bir hayal edin.
Bakın 1934 Ankarasından bahsediyorum ben.
Bugünün Ankarası gibi değil.
Yani öyle imkanlar dar.
Efendim sanatçı neredeyse yok.
Zaten çoğu yurtdışında
eğitime gönderilmiş.
E nasıl olacak?
Ankara dışından, İstanbul’dan sanatçı
getirilse doğru dürüst yatacak,
kalkacak yer yok, otel yok, yedirecek,
içilecek restoran yok
ağırlanacak yerler yok.
Ne yapacağız?
Efendim deniyor ki Münir Hayri Egeliye
o zamanki Türk Ocağı’nın müdürü,
edebiyatçı, yazar.
Sen librettosunu yazacaksın bu eserin
librettosunu, yani operanın sözlerini
sen yazacaksın.Hikayesini, sözlerini.
Peki kim besleyecek?
Diye sorulduğunda da düşünülüyor,
taşınılıyor.
Daha iki yıl önce Paris'ten eğitimini
tamamlayıp dönmüş olan Ahmet Adnan Saygun
geliyor akıllarına. Münir Hayri hemen
diyor ki Ahmed Adnana Paşa’nın emridir.
Sen yapacaksın ilk Türk
operasının bestesini.
Tabii diyor Ahmed Adnan.
Onur duyarım.
Gencecik bir besteci.
Çok da heyecan duyuyor, gurur
duyuyor gerçekten.
Peki diyor ne kadar zamanımız var acaba bu
eseri ortaya koymak için?
İşte diyor Münir Hayri Bey.
Burada bir sıkıntımız var.
Yirmi yedi gün kadar vaktimiz var deyince
Ahmet Adnan dehşete kapılıyor.
Ne demek yirmi yedi günümüz var.
mümkün değil öyle bir şey.
Bir opera eseri 2 yılda yazılır,
sizin haberiniz var mı?
Diye soruyor hatta.
Yani çok.
Uğraştınız, Gece gündüz çalıştınız ancak
bir yılda çıkarırsınız diye böyle kendi
kendine konuşurken Münir Hayri Bey
bence daha fazla oyalanmayın.
Yirmi altı gün kalmak üzere
diye korkutuyor onu.
El mahkûm.
Çalışmalar başlıyor.
Ahmet Adnan başlıyor geceli
gündüz çalışmaya.
Peki sanatçılar kim olacak?
Hani yok diye Ankara'ya.
Ankara’da. O zamanlar Musiki Muallim
Mektebi yenice açılmış.
Efendim müdürü de Zeki Üngör ve
İstiklal Marşı bestekarımız.
Müdüre gidiyorlar, ikisi birlikte
ve de diyorlar ki efendim bizim
öğrencilerinize ihtiyacımız var, onları
yetiştirmemiz gerekiyor.
Hem korist olacaklar, hem
enstrümanı olacaklar.
Geceli gündüzlü çalışmamız gerek
yetiştirebilmek için diyor ama Zeki Bey
bundan pek hoşlanmıyor.
Onlar da öğrenci dersleri var, sınavları
var, yok efendim deyip ayak diretiyor.
Fakat ısrarlar dan sonra bir
de paşanın emri ya zaten.
Peki peki tamam diyor ancak diyor.
Ancak Günde yarım saat alabilirsiniz
öğrencilerimi diye hakikaten
işi zora sokuyor.
Ama yapacak da bir şey yok.
Biliyorsunuz Atatürk en çok sanatçıya,
herkese ama en çok da sanatçılara
efendim saygı duyardı
Dolayısıyla emir demirdir.
Zeki Güngör öyle diyorsa
öyledir deniyor.
Sadece günde, yarım saatte çalışmalar
başlıyor ama zaman o kadar hızlı geliyor
gibi geçiyor ki, yirmi yedi gün, yirmi
altı gün kum saati böyle hızla akıyor.
Ahmet Adnan ne yapıyor peki?
Akşamları gidiyor evine partisyonları
onları böyle birer birer eliyle yarım
saat için, yarım saat için yazarak.
Beş keman, beş viyola, beş
viyolonsel sonra beş kontrovans.
Artık ne kadar enstrüman varsa krosslerin,
partisyonları
bunları teker teker
o zaman öyle teksir yani çoğaltma
makinası da yok.
Eliyle çoğalta çoğalta yazıp, ertesi gün
götürüp öğrencilerin önüne koyuyor.
peki efendi yarım saat, yarım saat
çalışılıyor zamanda.
Bir anda hızlı hızlı geçerken,
bakılıyor ki iyi gidiyor.
Çalışmalar. Artık geceleri sabahlara
kadar sarkıyor her şey tabii.
Ve Atatürk de bütün bu çalışmaları
gururla ve heyecanla izliyor.
Bebeği, yeni bir bebeği
daha dünyaya geliyor.
Cumhuriyet onun en değerli eseri.
Bebeği.
Cumhuriyet'in de yavruları
dünyaya gelmeye başlıyor.
Devrimlerle. Çok gurur duyuyor bundan.
Peki burada hemen ben baktım var mı?
Takip ediyorum bir yandan
neden opera istemiş olabilir, nerden
gelmiş olabilir aklına onu da hızlıca
lütfen araya sokayım size bu hikayeyi.
Efendim, 1913 senesinde Bulgaristan
Sofya'da askeri ataşe iken haber almış .
Şehirde bir büyük bir festival, opera
eserleri, temsilleri veriliyor.
Hele bir oyun, bir eser var ki, aman
Allah’ım çok ses getirmiş.
Herkes onu görmek istiyor.
Atatürk diyor ki Mustafa Kemal,
biz de görelim şu oyunu.
Ali Fethi Okyar da büyük elçi.
O zamanlar birlikte bu oyunu
görmeye gidiyorlar.
Bu eser, bu temsilin adı da Carmen.
Carmen operası izlemeye gidiyorlar.
O tıklım tıklım binanın içi kuyruklar,
bağırış çağırış ilk perdeyi izliyorlar.
Aman yarabbim, nasıl bir görkem, nasıl
bir ihtişam, bir keyif, güzellik.
Biraz suratı asılıyor,
bu düşünceye dalıyor.
Mustafa Kemal arada bir bakıyor.
Çar Çariçe Ferdinand eşiyle
birlikte locadalar.
Davet ediyorlar, beğendiniz mi?
Diye soruyorlar.
Davet ettikleri locada Mustafa Kemal’e
ve büyük elçimiz Ali Fethi Okyar’a.
E Mustafa Kemal.
Evet majesteleri tabii çok beğendim,
çok beğendim diyor
ama biraz böyle düşünceli.
Sonra yerlerine tekrar geçiyorlar, ikinci
perdede izleniyor, bitiyor.
Her şey büyük.
Efendim, ilgi alaka, bağırış çağırış
derken otellerine dönüyorlar.
Fakat uyku bir türlü gözüne girmiyor.
Mustafa Kemal'in sabaha karşı üç gibi.
Şakir zümrenin, yani Bulgaristan Eğitim
Komisyonu üyesi Şakir Zümrenin
kapısını çalıyor Mustafa Kemal.
Şakir Zümre fırlıyor yatağından.
Aman Allah'ım hayırdır inşallah.
Sabahın bu saatinde Aziz'in
buyrun içeri diyor.
Alıyor düşünceli
hala Mustafa Kemal oturduğu
yerden “Şakir,
ben şimdi anladım Balkan savaşlarındaki
yenilgimizin sebebini”.
Allah Allah bir kişi diye bir
şöyle bir dikkat kesiliyor.
Şakir demek istiyor ki ben sabah
bu saatinde gelmiş böyle.
Ben şimdi anladım, Balkan Savaşlarındaki
yenilgimizin sebebi baksana diyor
Bulgarlar için. “Ben bu adamları
daha da çoban zannederdim.
Bunlar operalarını , opera binalarını inşa
etmişler, sanatçılarını yetiştirmişler,
müzisyenlerini ve dekorlarını
yapmayı öğrenmişler.
Kostümlerini, her şeylerini.
Bunlar çağı atlamışlar.
Ne zaman, ne zaman bu medeniyet
düzeyine erişmişler, Şakir?
Acaba biz de bir gün bu medeniyet
düzeyine erişebilecek miyiz?”
diye soruyor.
Yıl 1913 ve 1934′de
aklına koyduğu medeniyet düzeyine
erişimini planlarını başlatıyor.
İlk cümleyi hatırlatıyorum.
Tekrar diyor ki ben şimdi anladım
bunların, bunlara neden
savaşlarda yenildiğimizi Balkan
savaşlarındaki yenilgimizin sebebini.
Çünkü savaş kazanmayı
aynı zamanda bir sanat olarak gören, zeka
işi olarak gören ve medeniyet işi olarak
gören bir zekadan bahsediyoruz.
Ayrıca ben Atatürkün ülkesini sanatla
yöneten lider olarak görüyorum.
Sanat zekasının ne kadar kıymetli
bir zeka olduğunu savaşları dahi
kazandırabileceğini, bize anlatmaya
çalışan bir liderimiz var.
İşte belki de o yüzdendir ki hep bir opera
olsun istiyor, tiyatrolarımız olsun
istiyor, müziğimiz senfoni olsun istiyor.
İşte o 1934'de akla koyduğu şeydi.
Özsoy, operamızla gerçekleştiriyor.
Efendim, vaktimiz çok daraldı.
Aslında hikaye müthiş hemen,
sona geliyorum.
Nihayet eser bütün zorluklarıyla çok
büyük zorluklarla ama alın teriyle
başarıyla gerçekleşiyor.
Eser hazır. Şahda Ankara’da.
Burada biliyorsunuz resmi heykel müzesi
o zamanki Türk Ocağı binasında
şah ağırlanıyor.
Eser sahnede, bütün oyuncular,
sanatçılar sahnede
ve Kral Baba, Şah Baba, Feridun
soruyor, ikiz oğullarını soruyor.
Herkes, bütün köylü halk orada
ama ikiz oğulları yok ortada.
Tûr ve irec nerede?
Diye soruyor.
Tûr ve irec
Hemen kısaca onları da anlatayım.
Neden birinin adı Tûr, diğerinin irec.
Bu ikiz kardeşlerin İran edebiyatında
Firdevsi’nin bir eseri vardır.
Şehnâme diye o eserin içinde
geçer bu hikaye.
Belki o hikayede Kral Şah Baba Feridun,
oğullarından ikiz oğullarından Tûra,
Türkistan'ı ve Çin'e armağan etmiştir.
İrece de
İran armağan etmiştir.
Ama şu bu ikiz kardeşler pek yaramaz.
Hep kavga ederler.
Onlar kavga edince de dünya
karmaşa içinde olur hep.
Herc ü merç olur, karanlık olur,
savaşlar olur.
Ne zaman ki bu ikiz kardeş el ele
verirler, dünyada mutlu olur, barış
içinde olur, toz pembe
çiçekler açar her yerde
Bu eserin çalışılmasını isteyen
de bu arada Atatürk’dür Hayriden isteyen.
Diğer efendim konu bu, tema, bu son sahne.
Herkes orda ama bir tek Tûrla İrec yok.
Şah Baba soruyor, herkes
burada ama Tûr nerede.
İrec nerde deyince Ozan sahneye doğru
yüzünü dönüyor ve bir elini kaldırarak,
kolunu kaldırarak locada oturan.
Şahı işaret ediyor.
İşte diyor İrec.
Sonra Atatürk'ün işaret ediyor.
İşte Tûr.
Her İranlı bir İrec.
Her Türk bir Tûrdur.
Diyerek sözlerini tamamlıyor.
Şah çok iyi anlıyor.
Onun ne demek istediğini fırlıyor
ayağa ve çok iyi bildiği Azeri lehçesiyle
kollarını açıp sarılıp Atatürk’e
gardaşım benim diyor.
Gardaşım benim.
Bizim kardeş olduğumuzu ona anlatmanın
en güzel yolunu bulmuş.
Bir opera eseri yaptırmış.
Hikayeye de, bu kardeşliğin
destanını da döşetmiş.
Efendim bu hançerelerden çıkan, yürekten
çıkan sevgi yankılarıyla da
kuşatırmış şahı.
İşte bu olaydan çok kısa bir süre sonra
da Cenevre Ön Anlaşması imzalanıyor.
Ardından Sadabat Paktı geliyor.
Ben diyorum ki, dünyanın en şık, en zarif,
en ince düşünülmüş diplomasi örneğini de
böylece bütün dünyaya öğretmiş oluyor.
Sanatın en iyi bir yankıllanma yolu
olduğunu, yöntemi olduğunu ben zaten
kendim yaşayarak biliyorum.
Ama Atatürk’ün de pek çok başarısından
taa yüzyıldan buraya
sesinin hala çıktığını, geldiğini,
duyulduğunu bilirsek
bana göre en güzel yankı
bu diye düşünüyorum.
Ben sürem doldu, teşekkür ediyorum,
inşallah başka ortamlarda
uzun uzun anlatırım size.